[Music]
it's the day of the fight all gets 20
for me case I versus Logan jg vs. Jake
the fight is in a couple hours
Logan Paul and Jake made a video
explaining how you can watch it by
paying with credit card we're gonna blur
that cuz f y'all dude he blurred his
card better than he blurred the body now
if you're looking to see the fight in
this video I got bad news for you just
take it from Jake himself and if you
think you're gonna be able to watch it
for free afterwards you're wrong because
there's people stripping down all of the
content that everyone else uploads so
the only way you're gonna be able to see
the fight is if you can get the
pay-per-view don't worry I will still
show the outcome at the end of this
video I know everyone's dying to know
who wins it's not like it doesn't matter
I'll also give my prediction on who I
think is gonna win and who I want to win
but first let's review the waited it was
yesterday and if you thought the press
conferences has been cringy it was
somehow they managed to make it even
worse they looked at all the press
conferences and they said you know what
not trendy enough we need to hop it way
more I'm the true Jody and welcome to
the chaos I versus Logan Paul win we're
gonna start off for some reason rocky
rocky was there I don't know how that
came in out of nowhere next up to the
stage
it's raka raka
[Applause]
why
Oh God
yes it is it is a bit awkward can we cut
this please the guard is loving it at
least I'm glad he's having a good time
and then for some reason he's fighting
scarce why have I not heard about this
next to the stage it's scarce it was so
scarce is here why is he not fighting no
that would actually make it the biggest
internet family-friendly show all right
he's on the scales
yikes weird in art 79 kilograms
scarce you know you're allowed to
breathe that breathe out please you
could die I'm concerned then they have
the most awkward stare off that has ever
been done probably ever raka put on his
clothes scares is like I don't know
should I put on a shirt or something
then he decides to keep it up anyone
else like that yes I didn't know whether
we're gonna kiss or punch each other you
could have gone either way you're right
man I can't wait for that fight I should
be pretty good
you can tell they clearly hate each
other so much drama so much tension
let's get to the point Jake came out
about 10 minutes later and damn Jake
look ripped he really bulked up men whoa
look at that
I promise I know it's gonna be a good
fight now
okay now I'm excited this is gonna be
epic
no just kidding after about five minutes
for a Jake Paul to take off his bling by
five other guys we finally get on the
stage any any moment on the scales Jay
Paul then Jake Paul makes a statement
about the fight it's gonna be a first
round knockout it's no gonna be yolk
it's not bloody hell gonna be oh is it
JK all right next up dingy my man he's
been training hard that's the number one
thing about dizzy he's been like oh I'm
working hard okay doesn't matter that I
lost my trainer okay I'm working hard
I'm training hard and you know dizzy
looks a little goofy but once he takes
it off to the glasses now we get to see
how hard he's trained finally he's gonna
look hard I know it for sure stepping
onto the scale oh no he's trained no de
gijón Oh whatever you been doing did she
he hasn't been training it's been
drinking bears you know I thought well
at least you know even if you lose the
fight at least by the end of it you'll
be ripped I know it's not about looking
red I know it's about the kills I'm just
joking it's a joke then Deji makes his
statement dead she always has the best
statement
he's always got the smartest things to
say that's why I like des G for those
three minute rounds that's gonna be the
tough part
you trained hard how do you train hard
edgy is the question what is he gonna
say we were meant to have a faceoff now
I didn't want one because he's too
scared to come at me so make any sense
how doesn't make any sense right
okay so we're meant to do a face of this
doesn't make any sense like we're
supposed to fight and stuff like okay
how does that nothing this doesn't make
any sense
where I am I I don't understand that
yeah whoa he's delusional
take fools delusional I'm gonna show him
all this tomorrow tomorrow August it's
tomorrow
it is realize that's tomorrow
holy Hank I don't believe it
the fight is tomorrow the great response
to the question dingy thank you very
much as always the moment we'll all be
waiting for Logan Paul versus KSA Logan
the maverick mug in the memory
let's go change the pitch gets a little
higher once Logan gets on stage next sub
ksi comes out finally
the reigning and defending oh no oh no
he did not
daddy's more than the holes girlfriend
oh my god he's had absolute mad plan
this thing this whole thing is just a
clown to show oh my god but my favorite
thing out of this whole waiting
it's the face up Logan posed a great
meet he's like Oh your breath is really
bad hey look what I got some gum alright
let's it's really bad here you go case I
and he takes it to day to day to day I
hope that was a piece of cyanide no I
don't that was a joke why did he take it
case I'm mysteriously dies before the
fight now we know why why did he think
it's so weird so strange
[Music]
I'm so confused this whole thing is so
weird now for me the fight is in a
couple hours has probably already
happened when you're watching this video
I wanted to give my thoughts before I
see it
who my honest predictions is I don't
know the outcome I really really want
digital win just purely from the fact
that from a boxing fight the winner will
be comedyshortsgamer everybody cuz
that's his YouTube channel name
comedyshortsgamer check out the win
I hope DG is going to win just because
he's the underdog and I think J can
handle losing better than dead G does
that make any sense however I think Jake
is going to win it
we'll see afterwards if I was right when
it comes to Logan and K Desai I same
thing with the case I have always
thought he was an idiot but watching
some of the podcasts that he's done
without all the drama without all the
crazy screaming at each other I realized
he's not an idiot
he's a level-headed dude and I really I
do respect him I do hope he wins purely
on the fact that he's he wants to do
boxing right so if he loses again Logan
he can't really do that he's really the
only one that got something to lose here
Logan has nothing to lose essentially I
think he's the one that's gonna come out
strongest throughout this whole thing
because of it I probably ripped into
Logan more than any other youtuber but I
actually do hope he does as well I do
hope this will be his way to move
forward I mean he's already apologized
what else can he do at this point like I
don't think anyone actually cares still
who's gonna win between ksi and Logan
it's so good because I don't know
like I don't know I think Logan's gonna
win it I think both the pole brothers
gonna take it and then I think it's
gonna be a rematch but that's just what
I think
place your bets if you don't know in the
comments right now I'll be back in a few
hours which will be in a second and
we'll see how it went oh boy here we go
here's the live footage of the fight I
got special permission to show it don't
worry guys this video won't get strike
because of it now if you watch the fight
I'm sorry I'm sorry you went through
that that was awful
okay I want my money back the whole chat
is this going refund everyone basically
case I versus Logan got a draw of course
and guess I just goes whoa let's do that
again that was fun no it wasn't fun okay
you guys made millions congratulations
but no fool me once okay fool me twice
no thank you
Jake one against edgy as I expected too
bad though it was a good fight good job
both oh yeah scarce lost against Rucka
Rucka and yeah that's it I won't I how
can I refund does it work